all right 1105 let's get started so the
agenda for today we're doing this whole
thing on the methods in human cognitive
neuroscience and i'm illustrating those
methods with the case of face perception
not just because i'm into face
perception but it's like a particularly
rich
domain of research where there's lots
lots to say about it from all these
different methods and so last time we
talked a bit about applying mars
computational theory level to face
perception we talked a teeny bit about
some behavioral data and a little bit
about functional mri what i'm going to
do today is quickly zoom through
speed speeded-up review of those things
and then we're going to get to some of
these other methods and there's a quiz
at the end all right
okay so um
[Music]
methods in
in any field of science are just there
to enable us to answer scientific
questions they're not to you know
impress our friends with all the fancy
things we know how to do or our
colleagues
they're just to answer questions and so
you always have to start with the
questions and so last time i listed a
bunch of questions not all of them but a
bunch of questions one would really want
to know about face perception if we were
to understand how it works in the brain
and last time we focused on these first
three so let me just do super quick
review
questions at the level of mars
computational theory we ask
what is the problem that's being solved
and why is that important to the
organism
what is the input what is the output how
much you get from that input to that
output right so for the case of face
perception here's a very simple version
of it here's an example of the input
goes in hits the retina
the stuff that we want to understand
happens in here and you have an output
okay so just even thinking about it that
way
we can already just see with common
sense that one of the big challenges in
solving this problem
is that faces look different every time
you see them
the lighting changes the orientation of
the face changes the hair changes the
mood changes all this stuff happens
people put on makeup they shave off
their facial hair they do all these
things to make it a real a big challenge
to recognize faces and yet we manage
really well so how do we do that
well our field has many methods to
address this question
last time i talked about one little
example of a behavioral study simple
cognitive psychology study measuring
behavior
where we showed that
that the way people solve this problem
is fundamentally different with people
they know well and people they don't
know well
so i showed an example that you know all
of you presumably would have no trouble
saying determining that those are all
pictures of the same person even though
the pics at the pixel level they're
wildly different
and yet you have a hell of a time saying
which of those images are of the same
people and which aren't and so the point
is that our ability to extract this
invariant representation that is to
figure out abstractly who is that
um
uh is really well to figure out that any
any of these images are the same as each
other is much better for familiar than
unfamiliar faces and that means we don't
have a perfectly general ability to take
any face and abstract out this
completely of
image independent version of it that's
what invariant representation is yeah
for the case of the dutch politicians
did they like ever do this study on
people who are like super
recognizers uh i don't know about that
but they did do it on um
uh people who are professional
um
uh you know tsa type people
right and i'll tell you guys about that
later but you could think about you know
you could think about whether you think
it might work better with those people
or not
okay everybody get this general point
here all right
so i i skipped over another simple
behavioral finding last time that i want
to mention now
and that is an extremely low-tech
charmingly low-tech and yet i think very
powerful discovery about face perception
one of the most important original
bits of evidence that face perception
might be a different thing in the brain
came from a phd thesis in this
department by a guy named robert yin
and he used the extremely high tech
equipment of
a stopwatch and paper
okay
so what did he do he presented faces to
people upright and he said study these
20 faces and then he tested them later
did you see this face did you see this
face did you see this face
and then he did the exact same
experiment on a different set of phases
but they were all upside down studied
upside down and tested upside down
okay and what did he find
he found what's known as the face
inversion effect
namely people do much worse at this task
when the faces are upside down here's
errors for inverted upside down errors
for upright at this task
even though importantly they were
studied and tested upside down or
studied and tested inverted
upright
okay everybody got what this shows okay
so that's cool um that this face
inversion um so but the further cool
thing is he showed that this face
inversion effect is greater for faces
than for other kinds of stimuli so he
tested lots of other things including
houses and stick figures
and he showed that that cost when you
turn the stimuli upside down is greater
that difference is greater for faces
than for other classes of stimuli
okay
so what that suggests
is that
face recognition may just work
differently in some deep way from
recognition of other classes of stimuli
and robert yin actually inferred in his
phd thesis way way back before any
imaging method that maybe there are
special parts of the brain for face
recognition and maybe face recognition
is just a totally different thing that's
why it is more affected by inversion
than recognition of other kinds of
things was there a question back there
yeah i was going to ask is that just
could that just be because spaces are
much more complex than houses or stick
figures in that
good question hang on to
good question that's that's a very good
question and many people have tried to
grapple with that um and actually about
10 years ago the idea that this
disproportionate effect for faces was
like you know standard textbook
completely accepted and now there's like
another round of people doubting it with
other kinds of stimuli so it's kind of
ongoing it's a very robust difference
but to say exactly what it is about face
stimuli versus other kinds of things
that is responsible for that difference
you can imagine
it's um it's subtle for the for the
purposes of this this course i'm trying
to like not quite lie to you guys but
give you the most standard view without
freighting you with every possible
objection to every little thing because
pretty much every finding there's
somebody who has a beef with it you know
and we'll tell you that's not really
true because bloody blood okay so yes
there are there's a little bit of uh
debate going on about this right now but
for the purposes of this course it's
pretty damn rock solid at least as an
empirical result okay
all right um so there's in fact lots of
versions of the um of the face inversion
effect one you may have seen before but
which is very amusing if you look at
faces like this that are upside down
they look
you know sort of normal
uh but then if you rotate them you
realize there's something deeply weird
going on okay so the point is you're
much more sensitive to those grotesquely
distorted faces when you see them right
side up than when you see them upside
down so that's another version of the
face inversion effect and there are many
many incarnations of this effect you'll
see another one later in the
in the lecture so um so where did we get
last time with these questions we got
that one of the major if not the major
central challenge in face recognition at
a computational level
is the fact that we deal with a huge
image variation each time we see a face
and yet somehow we're able to grapple
with it so to understand how face
recognition works would be to understand
what is the code ultimately nobody knows
right now but what is the code running
in our heads that enables us to do that
what is our mental representation of the
face that enables us to deal with this
problem
by looking at behavioral data
we got some evidence from the dutch
politician study that
whatever that representation is that we
extract from faces it's not independent
of the particular image it's not that we
have some you know platonic ideal of the
face that we can extract from any face
that lands on our retina a planet
platonic ideal of that person's face
right so whatever we're doing it's not
completely invariant um because we can't
do that so well with
unfamiliar faces okay
also as i just showed you related but
not exactly the same point
our mental representations of faces are
very sensitive to the orientation of the
face
more than our mental representations of
other classes of stimuli
okay
so those are just very simple uh
insights about the whatever whatever our
representations of faces are in our
heads just from simple behavioral data
okay
okay
um so let me just review some of the
strengths and weaknesses of
simple behavioral methods strengths are
they're good for characterizing the
internal representation right not with
huge computational precision they're
more like with gisty kind of ideas like
okay they're not very invariant they
depend on the orientation right that's
not very precise but it's a whole lot
better than nothing okay
that's what i mean by at least
qualitatively
they're good for dissociating mental
phenomena so you've already seen that in
the inversion effect it happens more for
faces than other things so that already
starts to tell us okay maybe however
whatever the code in our head is that we
use for face recognition maybe it's
pretty different than the code that we
use in our head to recognize objects
okay
um
okay it's also cheap it's really cheap
much cheaper than all the other methods
okay weaknesses
it doesn't behavioral methods alone
don't have any relationship to the brain
at least without doing extra work okay
and it it
it's not that they are useless until you
link them to the brain it's just that
the brain is a whole source of other
data and it's nice to link them because
then you can connect with all those
other data
also behavioral data are pretty sparse
like for the most part you have accuracy
and reaction time and that's it
and that's just not a whole lot of data
to work with you have to actually be
much smarter to be a behavioral
cognitive psychologist and you have to
be to be to to be a cognitive
neuroscientist where you have much
richer data to reason from like
cognitive psychologists really have very
very clever designs because they're
taking this extremely limited data and
trying to pull out interesting insights
about mental function
another way of looking at that is
here's you know an eyeball and a bunch
of processing going over stages and a
response right
with behavioral data all you have is
that response
but presumably for most of the mental
processes that go on in our heads there
are many different stages of processing
where different things are going on
computations tend to have multiple
stages and unfold over time and all we
have is output
so really what we want to be able to do
is characterize the whole sequence of
processes
and it's not that you can't get insights
about some of those intermediates from
behavioral data it's just much more
challenging
so if we had a way to look at those
things independently wouldn't that be
awesome
okay so there's lots of ways to do that
and a particularly good one is
functional mri so as i mentioned before
i mentioned this very of
brief very briefly this very early
experiment that i did way back
asking whether there is a region of the
brain that's selectively involved in
processing faces
and i'm going to put a slightly
different spin on it from what i put
before it's the same experiment same
data but i want to emphasize more the
logic of the experimental design because
you guys will be designing an experiment
on a different topic um
by
a due monday night okay that we're gonna
discuss in uh sunday night that we're
gonna discuss in class on monday okay
so we start with a hypothesis that
there's a special um there's a a region
of the brain that's selectively
responsive to faces that's the
hypothesis the way we test it is to pop
people in a scanner and show them faces
and objects the data that i showed you
before is that this little patch of the
brain remember this is a horizontal
slice back of the head left and right
are flipped so that little region in me
is right about in there everybody
oriented okay
that region responds much more to faces
than objects is that clear to everybody
what that is okay
so
um yes there's and you see that in most
subjects so yes there's a bit that
responds more to faces and objects
um but now let's consider the hypothesis
that that region is really selective to
faces per se
and the way you evaluate whether these
data so how strongly these data support
that hypothesis they're certainly
consistent with it but do they nail that
hypothesis fully
is to consider are there any other
alternative accounts we can think of
that are consistent with these data and
different from that hypothesis
is that clear it's really important
that's just the whole
kernel of scientific thinking
and evaluating evidence is asking
yourself that question is there any
other way we could get those data where
that hypothesis was wasn't true and if
so you got to grapple with it
so what you do next is you think about
our alternative hypotheses
to the one you started with
that is different accounts of the same
data
and so in in our case you guys suggested
a whole bunch i suggested a bunch
and though then the next thing i showed
you is that we can test those
alternative hypotheses at least these
ones here
by um first
what we did was i didn't really
emphasize this before but we re-ran that
experiment in a new bunch of subjects
each subject individually we found in
each subject the little bit that does
this
we write down exactly where that is in
the br in that person's brain okay now
that we've found that region that's
called a localizer run because we're
finding that region in each subject
individually
now we can ask it new questions
okay and so the new questions we asked
it last time
was to present faces and hands and we
found oh that region right there
responds like this
okay so the key ideas here is that we
can we can identify that region in each
subject individually with a functional
scan the reason that's important which
i'll carry on about in more detail later
is that the exact location of that
region varies from one subject to the
next
so if we just grab
you know the whole fusiform gyrus or the
whole lateral side of the fusiform gyrus
and each subject we'll get lots of stuff
that is that region and lots of cortical
neighbors it's something else okay
and if we grab you know if we took the
exact location of that region to my
brain and registered it to any of your
brains and said okay let's take the part
of your brain that registers spatially
as well as we can with mine
we're not going to exactly get the right
bit
so to study that thing we got to first
find it functionally and then we can ask
it new questions does that make sense
okay if anybody's unclear about that i
have actually online talks that go
through the whole logic of this in
painful detail and i'm happy to answer
other questions about it later
okay
so um i put the word conditions in red
because somebody asked one of the tas
what a condition was
and that's not stupid i should have made
that clear
this is just experimental design
gobbledygook that means
any any
okay what is the definition of condition
in an experimental design you have
things that you are manipulating and
measuring
okay so in this case we're manipulating
the stimulus
and we're measuring the magnitude of
response in the fusiform face area okay
or in the brain
so what we're manipulating in this case
is this the stimulus condition so that
will be one condition that's another
condition that's another condition does
that make sense
okay so for your experimental design
assignment for uh monday night
you'll be designing one or more
experiments
uh and you will be describing exactly
what conditions you are going to test
everybody clear on that
okay all right um so these data enable
us to rule out those hypotheses
and now you could ask okay
once you get more data like this have
you completely nailed that hypothesis is
there just no way that hypothesis could
be wrong now given these data and those
data and i'll let you percolate on that
there are ways it could be wrong
but they're you know you have to work
harder to come up with them okay
okay so
um skipping ahead just to give you the
gist this this field has been going on
for a long time uh and there are now
many many studies hundreds maybe even i
don't know god maybe even thousands i
don't know
uh studies of this region um in which
and so sort of a summary statement from
a long time ago in my lab we've tested
the response of this region to lots of
different kinds of stimuli with that
same method localize it in each subject
measure its response when people look at
that kind of stimulus okay
and so what we know now was that this
region is found in roughly the same
location
in pretty much every normal subject it
responds more to faces than to any other
kind of stimuli anyone has ever tested
let me just give you
one example here if you haven't seen
this stimulus before raise your hand if
you can tell what it is
okay
raise your hand if you can tell what
that is
okay some of you didn't quite get it yet
if you don't see it don't worry there's
nothing wrong with you it's a little
subtle
it's a face in profile eyes nose mouth
everyone got it
okay so here's the thing that's the same
stimulus it's just upside down another
version of the face inversion effect
in this case you can't even make
yourself see the face when it's upside
down if you think you see the the upside
down version of the face you probably
have the wrong bits the thing you think
is the nose probably isn't etc okay so
this is an extreme version of the face
inversion effect and it's a gift to an
experimental psychologist
why is that such a gift
because it's the same damn stimulus but
in one case you see a face and another
case you don't all we did was tip it
upside down
and the response of the fusiform face
area is much stronger
to the upright version when you see the
face than to the inverted version when
you don't
so that enables us to
stifle a whole line of attack from all
of these hardcore vision people
who early on said cowisher your face
area isn't really selective for faces
it's respect it's selective for these uh
spatial frequencies or those that kind
of contrast or this kind of shading
information it's like no same stimulus
it's just upside down it makes all the
difference it's really whether you see a
face or not yeah when you're measuring
the response of that example
did you like did you have it so that at
first when people that the first time
didn't recognize it and then you told
them we did that later not in this
experiment but we did that later and
then look to see like what
um
okay so uh it's a great question and
there's a lot you could do with that and
actually i think other people have
published studies like that since i
can't quite remember who all has done it
um
but what we did was most of our subjects
especially in the context of a whole
experiment we chose stimuli so that most
people could see the face in most of the
upright stimuli and most people could
not see the face in most of the inverted
stimuli it wasn't perfect at all they
didn't see faces in all of the upright
ones and they didn't fail to see them in
all of the inverted ones
and that's probably why this difference
in response is not you know two to one
it's but it's close
but you could do lots of other
experiments like that and you should
think about what kinds of designs would
be good ones to do
and what it would enable you to test
exactly
okay
all right
um
so okay i'm as usual taking too long to
do things so i'm just going to throw out
some questions for you to percolate on
and we will come back to them later in
the course
do these data the fact that you can see
this so robustly in all subjects and
that all this evidence suggests it's
really very selective for faces
does that tell us that this region is
innate
it's in the same place more or less than
pretty much everyone
does that mean it's innate
think about it
okay it's not immediately obvious
another question
does the fact that this thing responds
so selectively to faces in pretty much
everyone
um
mean that it's necessary for face
recognition
what do you guys think about that
in the sense of like does that
necessarily mean that if you lost that
thing you wouldn't be able to recognize
faces isabelle is that isabelle yes um
well
i would think would you really test that
i promise you
um
exactly
exactly
exactly and we'll talk more about that
in a moment the critical thing is that
it's fabulous and powerful and cool to
be able to find this thing in everybody
measure its response it's taken us very
far but
just the fact that people have that
thing doesn't tell us that you need it
for face recognition it just tells you
what turns on when you recognize faces
okay
this is really important we'll
keep coming around to this
um
does this tell us how face recognition
actually works in the human brain
no
i mean it's important but it's like
barely step zero unfortunately the field
is kind of still at step zero for most
things
uh step zero is better than i guess i
don't know maybe i should call it step
one uh anyway it's something but we
doesn't tell us how it works
okay
all right so advantages and
disadvantages of functional mri
advantages it is as i mentioned last
time the best spatial resolution
available for studies on normal subjects
without opening their heads okay
that's what it means to say non-invasive
disadvantages
as i just said we don't know just
because we see a response there doesn't
mean that that region is causally
involved in perception or cognition or
experience
we don't know exactly what is going on
at a neural level underlying that bold
response that blood flow change it could
be any metabolic change not necessarily
neuronal spiking okay so it's a little
bit it's very indirect and a little
imprecise
spatial resolution is much better than
anything else in humans but it's
appallingly bad compared to
anything that people who work on animals
can do or they routinely record from
individual neurons or you know even
dendrites on a
on a neuron
we are summing over
hundreds of thousands of neurons in each
pixel or voxel that we measure with
functional mri
it's very expensive
it's a little cheaper than that here but
in most places it's more than 600 bucks
an hour that is a lot
um there are other
they're parts of the brain where it's
really hard to get any signal for
various physics he
reasons
and it makes a loud noise which is not
always a problem but it's a problem for
some things like scanning infants or
like doing auditory experiments
the temporal resolution
is not even close to the time scale on
which vision happens okay so vision is
really fast
um
and
functional mri is really slow
right it's slow why is it slow
yeah blood levels take time to change
yeah just takes a long time for blood
blood flow to change after the increase
in neural activity
all right
okay so back to our questions that we're
asking about face perception where did
we get with functional mri well actually
from both behavior and functional mri it
kind of looks like we have a distinct
system for recognizing faces than for
for recognizing everything else
i don't think we've totally nailed it
yes quick question regardless
so it's uh the resolution is the order
of like a couple of seconds
yeah some people would say you could get
it down to a couple hundred milliseconds
but that's debated you have you have to
go to great lengths to do that normal
functional mri a couple seconds at best
all right
so let's let's consider this next
question how fast does face recognition
happen
now that may seem like a completely
arbitrary question to ask but it's not
remember we're trying to understand the
computations that are running in your
head when you recognize faces
and you might imagine some computations
that are iterative that involve
multiple repeated
testing of hypotheses generative models
whatever things that involve lots of
iterated feedback versus things where
you just have a feed-forward sweep of
the visual system and so there might be
very different time scales for those
different kinds of
mental processes
uh so we just went through this
functional mri is not going to answer
this question it's just not it's a
bummer but that's life we're adults
we're going to just move on and use a
different method
okay so there's a bunch of different
methods one is i kind of been around
forever you glue electrodes on the head
right sometimes you push the hair apart
or try to find bald people and glue
electrodes right on there and you can
use in the old days you know about 10
electrodes or you can use in more modern
devices these nets with you know a few
hundred
electrodes that you settle onto the head
and so then you just measure directly
electrical potentials right on the scalp
okay so what's cool about that is it's
totally non-invasive and it gives you a
beautiful online temporal measure of
underlying neural activity
what's not so cool about it is that
electrical potentials blur all over the
scalp and the spatial resolution is
really awful
okay
so the analogy has been made
that it will be like sticking a
microphone on the um inside of the top
of a football stadium
and collecting audio there like you
would know
when a touchdown was scored there's a
lot of noise all over it's like okay
there's an event we detected that event
right you might be able to tell a touch
ball from a touchdown from something
else i don't know about football so i
can't tell you what else anyway
something else some other event that
could happen okay
um
so that will be useful for some things
but kind of crude
um
but you'd have a hell of a time telling
anything else like what one person is
saying to another person in the
bleachers okay
so that's the old analogy this is
changing slightly
um and i will get to that later
but first i want to briefly mention the
one of the assigned readings that i just
hoped you guys could figure out on your
own but just in case you were confused
about it the point i wanted you to get
from the thorpe reading
is he's asking how how quickly can we
tell if an image contains an animal or
not it's a kind of way to say how fast
is object recognition okay
so what does he do he has people look at
a bunch of images and they press a
button if this button if it's an has an
animal and this button if it doesn't
really simple task
so first question is why not just use
those reaction times we can measure how
fast it takes for people to press a
button after the image comes on why not
just use that
does that tell us how fast object
recognition occurs
yeah jimmy it doesn't because if you
perceive it and then you it also
activates the motor neurons
yeah i have to take all that time to
figure out okay i see the animal okay
which button is that and then like which
finger do i push and then you got to
send a signal all the way down here
conduction velocity all the way out down
to your finger that takes a long time
and so it includes all that motor stuff
in with the perceptual stuff we can make
some guesses about how long that
motor stuff takes but it's still not
very precise
so the point of the thorpe paper is
they're basically trying to collect a
reaction time out of the neurons in the
head right
so they're trying to actually collect
it's essentially what they're collecting
in this case is more the motor response
because they're collecting responses
over frontal lobes right and we haven't
talked about this much but all of the
visual stuff we've been talking about
all happens in the back of the head okay
more motor planning stuff mostly happens
in the front of the head and so they're
collecting responses out of here
averaging over a bunch of frontal
responses and they see the average
response when there's an animal this is
just potential average over those
frontal electrodes is like this and when
there's no animal it's like that
and so what does that tell us
about how fast people can distinguish
whether an image has an animal or not
yes yeah it's less than that number
less than
1 516. okay why less than 150
i i've read the paper so it's kind of
cheating that's okay that's good that's
fine
so
it gives you like a bound
uh the 150 second news giving you a
bounce saying
some process has been registered and now
you're trying to do something else
uh in the case of non-admins right
so that's the deviation starts telling
you that okay two different actions have
started taking place yep so by that time
the image ought to have been sort of
fully processed so
that should be something less than that
number one yeah yeah i did everybody get
that there's it's it's actually quite
subtle so
so the key thing is the these curves
diverge right there at 150. so that
tells you that by 150 milliseconds
something in your brain is happening
different if there's an animal and not
an animal
okay that's the key question but what is
that something
it may be your motor preparation of the
response in that case the actual visual
part happened before because you
wouldn't know which button to press if
you hadn't already recognized it okay
so
it's
an upper bound for when that process
happened because maybe it happened
before and we're looking at a later
stage
okay
does that make sense
um but also it's an upper bound
for the beginning of that process
because the fact that those electrode
responses have diverged doesn't mean
you've finished processing whether it's
an animal or not
okay so it's kind of a subtle business
reasoning from this
okay
okay
so
um that's all that
so um that's a case with detecting
animals what about faces to get back to
our theme for today
um yes you can learn about the speed of
face detection at least with erps and so
here's the first paper that did that
back in 1996 they had electrodes over
where's where are these just right
around here and here i actually have
those electrode locations tattooed and
my on my scalp
color coded anyway yes is erp just
the same as an eeg just specifically yes
exactly um it is
it's the same as an eeg except what you
do is you
time lock the data collection to
stimulus onset so it actually stands for
event related potential and the reason
it's event related is you collect all
those trials and you time lock to
stimulus onset and then you signal
average
okay
i had a slide on that but i took it out
as to detail but that's exactly the idea
yeah
so here stimulus onset is you know right
around here this is time going this way
and what you see it's hard to see here
but the faces are right there and at 170
milliseconds after stimulus onset
there's a bigger bump
for faces at you know an electrode
approximately here
uh and even more so actually even more
so over the right hemisphere right there
okay compared to cars and scrambled
faces and stuff like that yeah what is
your exactly measuring is it just like
activity yeah so again it's it's
electrodes glued on your scalp okay
or just stuck there with some kind of
icky gel okay
and so they're just measuring potentials
and so the idea is it's neural activity
somewhere underneath those electrodes
but maybe like anywhere within
you know in you know inches like along
probably averages over much of the whole
lobe underneath so it's very spatially
blurry
it's giving you some kind of summed idea
of activity under that electrode makes
sense electrical activity because it's
the direct electrical consequence of
neural activity it's very precisely time
locked
okay
unlike functional mri which is going by
way of blood flow
okay
okay
so that tells us that we have a phase
specific response at 170 milliseconds
and that's
sort of more evidence that there might
be something special in the brain for
face recognition that's useful
it tells us that faces are discriminated
from non-faces
they've begun to be discriminated from
non-faces by 170 milliseconds after the
stimulus comes on
make sense
okay
now do we know whether the signal is
coming from the fusiform face area
no we have no idea it's like probably
somewhere in the back of the head
because you get it better with
electrodes back here than electrodes up
here but that's about it that's all you
can tell
um
so can we do a little bit better
localizing the source of that signal
well maybe a hair better using a very
similar method called
magnetoencephalography
so this is a picture that chris brewer
took
of
laila ishik postdoc in my lab and me in
the meg system this is in
on the other side of the building
so meg is a lot like um eeg and erps
except it detects magnetic fields not
electric fields okay and it does this by
having these um several hundred um
devices that are placed right next to
your head in this big hairdryer thing
there's like 300 devices in there that
measure
teeny tiny magnetic field changes that
happen with neural activity
the crux of the idea is
this is a cross section through the
brain so remember from uh angry bill's
dissection right this is cortex here and
this is underlying what is this stuff
underneath underneath it
sorry
white matter yeah well those are all the
fibers okay so
the activity that underlies perception
and and cognition mostly happens in the
gray matter where the cell bodies are
um and so a lot of that activity goes in
a direction perpendicular to the
cortical orientation with these cells
that cross the cortical surface like
that
so if you remember 802
if you have activity that's going
through the cortex like this
right hand rule
the magnetic field here
is going to be that's a consequence of
that electrical activity in this
direction
is going to mostly stay within the
cortex everybody see how that's true
that's not so great because our
detectors are out there outside the
cortex
however consider the activity that's in
the sulcus in here in this fold of the
brain
electrical activity in this direction
right hand rule
will stick outside the brain and we can
detect it with our magnetic sensors does
that make sense
so you can sort of see
um the most cortical activity better if
it's in a sulcus or at least
in part of the cortical surface that's
perpendicular to the scalp where the
detectors are just because of the
orientation in the right hand rule
okay
so it primarily sees
activity in the in the folds or soul
site not in the outer bumps or right
field strengths are minuscule as a
consequence of neural activity so the
fields we measure are 10 to the minus
13th tesla
a million times weaker than the earth's
magnetic field
so you can imagine that if you set up an
meg system
you need a lot of shielding we had a
whole rigmarole when the
meg system was set up in this building
because it's right near the um the
subway and the train
and so there are many many layers of
copper shielding to protect it so we can
detect these teeny tiny
magnetic fields from the brain's
activity with
separated from the noise of the outside
world which is much greater in magnitude
okay
so um all right so actually meg was
invented here at mit by this guy david
cohen
and this is the first mg device ever
built very cool
way back in
1968
um and
what can it tell us about face
perception well a lot i'll give you just
one
rudimentary example
that n170 that you can detect with scalp
electrodes you can also detect with
magnetic sensors on the head so here's
some of our data from a long time ago
this is the
strength of the magnetic field at sites
right about you know out here
and you can see a face selective
response also at 170 milliseconds just
like you can
uh with scalp with scalp electrodes
um
so that tells us that at least you've
you've started to detect faces by 170
milliseconds that's pretty fast
and again it's more evidence that
there's specialized machinery these data
don't yet go beyond the eeg data the erp
data from electrical potentials
but they might in principle and there's
lots of ongoing work trying to do that
okay
overview advantages of these these
methods both eeg and and meg they're
non-invasive that means you don't need
to open the head a very good thing
especially if you're the subject
they have very good temporal resolution
and if we want to see computations
unfolding over time in the brain this is
a good way
um
i just said why would care about that
okay
so far well never mind i'm going to skip
this point not that important we will
get back and do more sophisticated
things with eeg and meg and subsequent
lectures
disadvantages
spatial resolution is terrible
and this is another kind of ill-posed
problem so just as the brain is facing
lots of ill-posed problems in perception
and cognition
we scientists are facing ill pose
problems when we collect
electrical or magnetic activity at the
scalp and try to infer the exact
location in the brain where it's coming
from
it's a similar problem to the problem of
invariant object recognition there are
many possible configurations of sources
in the brain
that could give rise to the same set of
electrical and magnetic fields out of
the scalp
and that means it's ill-posed we don't
have a way to get a unique solution okay
so all that to say
we can't figure out the exact sources we
can make some guesses that's not very
good
so what do we do just give up
no we use another method
um so here's an amazing method
this is the one method in humans that
gives us high resolution in both space
and time and that's when we have the
very rare opportunity to record directly
from inside the human brain this happens
only in the context of neurosurgery
okay
so
neurosurgical patients like this guy
here we'll meet in a little bit
this guy had intractable epilepsy
and most people with epilepsy are
treated well by drugs that suppress
seizures
but some people are just not responsive
to drugs and if the seizures are bad
enough they can be you know totally life
disrupting if they happen
dozens of times a day you just can't
live a normal life and under those
rather extreme circumstances
sometimes the best option is
neurosurgery that is trying to find the
the source of that of those seizures and
trying to remove it surgically
okay so you hope you never have to go
through this or anyone you care about
has to go through it it's no picnic
but actually this surgical treatment is
often very effective okay
so when neurosurgeons
decide to do this they have to remove a
whole piece of
of skull bone to get access to the brain
they have to go through what structure
that ann treesman and treesman and
graybill showed you in her dissection
the other day
what do you have to after you take off
the
the um
a skull patch yes
dura mater exactly that nice big piece
of white leathery stuff that was sitting
over the surface of the brain so you
need to take off a skull piece of skull
then you need to like you know cut
through and push apart the dura and then
what they sometimes do is stick
electrodes straight on the surface of
the brain
okay and they do that for two reasons
one
if they have enough of them sampled far
enough apart they can kind of
triangulate and figure out where is the
source of the seizure so the patient
hangs out in the hospital for a week or
so with these electrodes in their head
waiting to have seizures and then when
they have a seizure the clinicians can
figure out where the source is so they
know what bit to cut out
okay
the other reason to do this is to map
functions because once the surgeons
decide they have to go in and cut
they want to try to not cut out any of
the most important parts i don't know
what it means to have unimportant parts
of the brain but you know they try to
they try to avoid language regions and
stuff like that because then you know
patients really notice if they lose
those things
right or motor control regions okay so
they map out functions where they might
be planning their route okay make sense
now
some of these patients are very kind and
generous to the world and say
yes you scientists can measure responses
in my brain while i look at your damn
stimuli
and so whenever we can we ask them
please please please can we show you
some pictures or play you some towns or
have you read some sentences while we
record from your brain
and some of those patients very kindly
let us do that
and that gives us the most amazing data
you can get from human brains
so for example i had a rare opportunity
to do this a few years ago from this
lovely guy who was undergoing
neurosurgery in japan and while he had
electrodes in his brain a colleague of
mine was there and emailed me and said
look where these electrodes are right
near regions i care about do you want to
show us some stimuli and we can we'll
record responses from those electrodes
and i said damn straight i want to send
you some stimuli
so my students and i stayed up for a
couple days and made some stimuli and
shot them to japan and got some
responses from those very electrodes
and here they are
so this is a strip of
a pair of two parallel strips of
electrodes right along the fusiform
gyrus right where the fusiform face area
should be in most people
and here are the responses of each of
those electrodes like 174 is here what's
173 and so forth and what you see is
this batch of electrodes right here this
is the response when the patient was
looking at faces and these are the
responses when they looked at a whole
bunch of different kinds of stimuli
objects and this guy's japanese so we
showed him kana and kanji and digit
strings and other kinds of stuff
very low response to those other things
this is a extremely selective response
right it's much more selective than you
see with functional mri because we are
recording directly from the surface of
the brain
further we have time information this
axis here is time and you can see that
that response well you can't see the
axis but that response starts up at
around 130 milliseconds and peaks up
there at around 170. everybody clear
what we're seeing here
and why this is so vastly better than
either functional mri or mg or erps or
anything else
makes sense
okay so these are very very precious
data
um
okay
uh
okay
nonetheless the electrodes in this in
this case
are about two millimeters across
each electrode
and that is about the size of a
functional mri pixel or voxel
okay a little bit smaller
it has less blurring because functional
mri blurs spatially because it's looking
at blood flow so this is a more precise
spatial measurement than functional mri
but it is still averaging over probably
tens of thousands of neurons down from
hundreds of thousands of neurons with
functional mri okay
so can we ever get responses from
individual neurons in the human brain
yes occasionally
in fact a paper came out on the bio
archive a couple months ago i was on
this guy's phd thesis defense and this
is a guy who works with a neurosurgeon
on long island and this neurosurgeon
specializes in epilepsy
neurosurgery and he's very interested in
not
damaging people's ability to recognize
faces
and so he sticks electrodes to map out
neural activity and to discover seizure
foci before the neurosurgery he sticks
electrodes in
parts of the brain near the fusiform
face area
so this is a slice like this through the
brain i should do before horizontal
slices okay so left and right are
flipped that region is like you know
right in there everybody oriented with
this picture here so that this is an mri
image of this person was it was scanned
with functional mri before the
electrodes were put in and that shows
you their fusiform face area right there
okay so now the neurosurgeons put in
electrodes for clinical reasons but the
electrodes this surgeon uses have these
little tiny micro wires that come out of
the tip of the electrode that enable him
to record from individual neurons
okay
and so
these guys for the first time have
recorded from individual neurons in the
fusiform face area in humans
and here's an example of one of these
neurons
so
here different stimuli here a bunch of
different face stimuli body stimuli
houses patterns and tools
and this shows you
time across here each one of those dots
is
this is all the response of a single
neuron that's been identified in a human
brain
each dot is an action potential is a
spike out of that neuron so you can see
them happening over time here to all the
faces this is an average amount of
activity to all of the faces and average
amount of activity to all the other
stimuli
okay makes sense
so that's pretty breathtaking to me
because i've been using these very
indirect methods for a long time
inferring that they must result from the
average across a lot of neurons doing
that but it's pretty awesome to actually
see individual neurons doing that
yeah
okay
here's the time course of responses just
averaging over this raster over time
showing you a similar time course to
what i've shown before
uh and in this guy's thesis he found
three other
phase selective neurons in the ffa
but the electors are so rarely in the
right location that they only have a few
in this whole thesis and there they are
yeah
well even if we can measure individual
neurons we don't really know like which
neuron it is right if i wanted to go
back and find the same neuron again
that's pretty much impossible forget it
yep
yep so
people like me who almost never get to
see responses from individual neurons
and human brains have kind of neuron
envy you know it's like everyone else in
this building has they can measure stuff
from like dendrites or ion channels or
individual neurons they can do all this
amazing stuff but actually there are a
lot of limits in those limitations in
those methods too and you just put your
finger on one of them so there's like
okay they found those neurons they're
four neurons we can't go back and find
those neurons again that's that right
and they're probably
subtly different in different brains
right so they're it's it's cool and
powerful but has still has many
limitations
okay
um
does this tell us that these neurons are
involved in discriminating one face from
another or just detecting faces can we
tell from these data
are they just saying here's a face
are they saying that's joe
did they
have different conditions for different
people
these are different faces here
what do you think what are these neurons
doing
yeah just right from that
you can see
you mean just detecting
no just say more what do you think
they're doing uh like they're just
selected from faces
there's no evidence to show them and
distinguish different places
well how about this these are different
faces here
these are different faces here
was the task did the task involve them
sort of acknowledging what phrases what
did they have to put into their face
nope they do they're just sitting there
looking at stuff
okay so bottom line is we don't know
from this it could be just responding
and saying essentially there's a face
but the fact that there's different
responses to different faces
suggests that maybe there's some
information in there
like if you ran some machine learning
code on this
you could tell a little bit which face
was being presented because those
neurons are responding differently to
different faces
yeah
is it really like if they just show the
same face repeat that you wouldn't just
feel like
okay very good question very good
question that's why i said suggests
right you're absolutely right that could
be just noise it could be that if you
presented the same face every time you
get that same distribution you're
exactly right
and so we will talk not next time i
think wednesday next week but anyways
very soon we'll talk about methods that
enable us to exactly deal with that
question and ask is there actually
information
in this pattern of response across
neurons or voxels or whatever it is
or is that just the noise of variation
yeah okay
well how many neurons are in the
epidemic
oh good question um
let's see uh
i would say um
i think a few million so let's think
about it each each voxel is about um
a half a
half a million and they're typically
maybe like
30 voxels something like that somewhere
on the order of 20 million something
like that i mean with huge error bars
okay
okay
so um
this is cool and tantalizing but it
doesn't even tell us what these neurons
what exactly they're participating in it
doesn't tell us if those neurons are
telling that person which face is there
or maybe what facial expression the
person has or how old they are or
whether they're male or female or god
knows what else right
and it certainly doesn't tell us how
those neurons get that information okay
still it's cool
okay so intracranial recording
both with the um the grids that i showed
you and the single unit version
advantages are this is the only method
in humans that has both pretty good
spatial resolution and temporal
resolution at the same time
um disadvantage well you need to have a
craniotomy which is no picnic to put it
mildly you need to have a huge piece of
your skull removed and
neurosurgery and that means that the
only times we get to do this are when
it's required clinically
and everything is under control of the
doctors as it should be right so the
doctors make all the choices about where
the electrodes go
and we just get to sit in the background
and say please please please look at
these stimuli
but try not to hassle the patients too
much
right now there's a patient in albany
new york who has electrodes right over a
really exciting part of the brain to us
that i'll talk about in a few months
this patient has electrodes that respond
specifically to music we will talk about
that later it's pretty amazing
and for the last couple days dana and i
have been mostly dana has been
collecting stimuli because we really
want to ask questions about the response
of those electrodes and this patient is
not too thrilled listening to our
stimuli so we finally said oh you okay
you can watch tell the patient they can
just do instagram on their phone and
we'll play the stimuli in the background
so
hopefully we'll have cool data from that
soon
okay so to say that these data are
limited and hard to control is an
understatement like we basically can't
control it at all all we can control
occasionally is the stimuli
and
and it also like functional mri just
because we see those beautiful responses
it doesn't tell us
how how those responses are connected to
behavior
right
so that's a that's a real challenge
so that won't do
uh we need to get beyond this problem i
keep saying this method is great but it
doesn't tell us the causal role of that
neural phenomenon in in cognition and
behavior as scientists science is all
about discovering causal mechanisms
right we're not just interested in what
is correlated with what we want to know
what's causing what that's really of the
essence and so we need to do better here
uh so what are we gonna do somebody
mentioned a while ago maybe it was
isabelle that one of the ways to do that
and ask whether the face area is
causally involved in face perception
is to look at a case where the face area
is altered okay so there's a bunch of
ways to do that
and one of them
okay that's just a review we said faces
are recognized fast but we haven't
learned much more
how do we
test causality okay patients with vocal
brain damage
here is a patient these are vertical
slices through the back back of this
patient's head okay let me get oriented
this slice is maybe like this here and
as you go rightward you're marching back
in the brain like that everybody
oriented
what's this thing right there
yeah cerebellum right
that thing right there is this patient's
lesion that spans several slices going
back like that
and this patient's lesion
looks a whole lot like my ffa there's my
ffa
greater response to faces and objects on
similar slices
we don't have functional mri from this
patient so we don't know exactly where
this guy's ffa was but there's a good
bet that it was blitzed by that lesion
okay because it's right in the zone
where it usually lands
and this patient
can't recognize faces at all
and importantly
patient is absolutely normal at
recognizing objects
no problem whatsoever at recognizing
objects
okay
how does this take us beyond functional
mri
speak up
yeah say more what what is it what does
it tell us so because the because of the
fact that like that theory is damaged
and then
it makes it to like not being recognized
because i could see how there's
something to do with that period exactly
exactly it says you need that bit to
recognize faces but also says something
else
what else does it
you don't need it for recognizing
objects so this is actually really
strong evidence that that bit of brain
is
very specialized for face recognition
specialized and necessary for face
recognition
okay
okay
so um
so person still attacked faces
oh yes good question absolutely like
okay so let me just distinguish this
person here
um who has prosopagnosia that means a
selective deficit and face recognition
like jacob hodes who i described
yesterday who has no brain damage
whatsoever but has just never been able
to recognize faces at any point in his
life
so this syndrome can arise just from
some weird developmental thing where
you're atypical and you're just really
bad at it or it can result from damage
to that part of the brain okay so now
we're talking about the case of damage
but in both cases
people with prosopagnosia have no
problem knowing that a face is a face
they just don't know who it is
okay
yeah
has there ever been a case
of people who can't recognize spaces who
um
indeed
indeed jacob hodes who i talked about
last time who is just absolutely awful
at face recognition including family
members close friends can't do it like
not at all
he has a very normal looking fusiform
face area
so after i told you that i had that
conversation with him
a dozen years ago or something like that
i scanned him
and he had a beautiful fusiform face
area like textbook it looked
well looked like mine which is a damn
fine one if i if i do say so myself
um and um
i looked at that and i went oh [ __ ]
i better publish this before someone
else does and i didn't get my act
together and then a whole bunch of
papers came out saying oh people with
developmental prosopagnosia have normal
looking face areas take that canvasser
what do you say about that
and it was a little shocking
but upon further reflection it's not
really devastating right i mean it's
bracing it's informative
but it tells you
that having a face area that is a region
that responds more to faces and objects
isn't sufficient
for normal face recognition
right you need other stuff
what might that other stuff be well the
circuits in there need to work right
it's not enough to just respond more to
faces and objects to recognize faces
they need to be able to distinguish
faces from objects we don't know if
that's working right
what else do you need
memory absolutely
yes you need to remember faces what else
[Music]
could be but in jacob's case it was like
close friends he couldn't recognize
so what's another possible account of
how could he have a normal face area and
yeah david it might be a
gap between
recognizing on face and connecting that
to recognizing a person
yeah
yeah or to put that neuroanatomically
you got to get the information out of
there
like maybe for all we know
that little face area is working
perfectly maybe that face area knows who
that person is in a sense
but if the connections out of that brain
region to the rest of the brain
are messed up it doesn't do you any good
right you need to be able to read that
information out and act on the basis of
it right
anyway that's a big sidebar
point is you can have prosopagnosia
either as just a developmental disorder
or as a result of brain damage oh god i
knew that was going to happen all right
um
so okay so very briefly um it s it
messes up ability to discriminate and
recognize faces not your ability to
detect a face right so spurted ass it's
not just you can't uh tell the thing as
a face they're fine with that
importantly they're normal at voice
recognition okay so it's not that
they're confused about distinguishing
one person from another they can do it
fine
from audition just not from vision
um when the in the rare cases where the
lesion is small it can be very specific
leaving object recognition intact more
often there's kind of a blurry mess you
have a big lesion and a bunch of things
are affected
okay so we've talked about that okay now
it's very important in neuropsychology
reasoning like we want to say okay
that's really powerful the case of
prosopagnosia you lose that bit you
can't recognize faces
um
and and that that establishes a kind of
causality that we didn't have before
okay with just functional mri
but is that sufficient to say that that
region is specialized for face
recognition only
it's not whenever i ask this the answer
is no your task is to say why
how could you have
great difficulty recognizing faces and
be okay at object recognition and yet
not have a deficit that's specific to
faces
what what are how how might that arise
you guys have suggested this hypothesis
in different contexts before
yes you look like you know
um
sort of um but the question here is
how if you if you
okay let's just start bare bones you
have a lesion
you get around fine in the world you can
do everything else but you have a real
problem recognizing faces
does that mean that the region lesioned
is necessary for face recognition per se
there might be
like other ancients
right
that's true there could be other things
going on absolutely but let's suppose
they're not let's suppose you had good
reason to think there weren't yeah it
could be like uh
like could be a path it could be like
one point in a pathway that's true it
could be totally a point in a pathway
absolutely that's another account what
else
oh i i couldn't give lots of comments he
said like maybe you damage a pathway
yeah
maybe there's some other function we
haven't tested
let's all these are very good
alternative hypotheses you guys are very
good at this the one i'm fishing for is
maybe face recognition is just harder
than object recognition
maybe the part that's damaged is just
generically involved in object
recognition
but you damage part of the object
recognition system and face recognition
takes a bigger hit because it's harder
right does that make sense
do you see how the case of prosopagnosia
is consistent with that so that means we
cannot infer from these data alone that
that region is specialized for face
recognition
now we can do various things like test
them on really hard versions of object
recognition and people have done that
but there's another kind of data that
are really powerful here
and that's when we have the opposite
syndrome
okay
so there's a only a couple cases of this
the best one is called ck published in a
paper in 1997. you don't need to
remember that the point about this is
that this guy has the opposite syndrome
he's severely impaired at object
recognition he can't tell a chair from a
table from a car from a toaster
but he's a hundred percent normal at
face recognition
totally normal at face recognition in
fact better than average
do you see how that's in some ways even
more powerful evidence
that face recognition goes on in
specialized brain machinery than the
case of prostagnosia
like face recognition isn't even like a
special thing that sits on top of normal
object recognition it's a totally
different pathway you can have no
ability to recognize objects and you're
okay at face recognition does everybody
see how that's really powerful
and how those two kinds of evidence
together are vastly more powerful than
either one alone okay
well that's called a doubled association
um we'll skip all of that for now double
dissociations are particularly powerful
examples uh powerful forms of evidence
in cognitive neuroscience where we have
opposite syndromes that collectively
make it really hard to wiggle out and
come up with alternative accounts other
than that
there's a there's a bit of brain that's
really specialized for face recognition
it's not just that face recognition is
harder or else you'd never get this
syndrome
okay
all right i just wanted to finish that
point okay now how much time do i have
until the quiz
50 minutes okay good um okay good we're
going to skip over tms i'm sorry about
that guys someday i'll learn to time
things in a lecture actually i knew this
was going to happen just
we'll get back to tms later
and we will skip to
the most amazing method in all of
cognitive neuroscience
for which we're going to come back to
this dude who you met before who has the
face selective responses in that part of
his brain
okay remember how i said that even
though these data are gorgeous and
spectacular and the only way we can get
high spatial and temporal resolution
together but they don't tell us
causality
right that's true here
resolution doesn't get you causality to
test the causal role of something you
need to mess with it
okay
so it turns out that sometimes the
neurosurgeons electrically stimulate
through those same electrodes
and they do that to test the function of
those regions causally
they also do it to test their hypotheses
about the location of the seizure foci
okay
so in those rare cases where you have a
patient like this with selective
electrodes like that
where the clinicians decide that they
are going to electrically stimulate
through some of those electrodes then
we're in a position to kind of have it
all scientifically right i don't mean to
be so crude this is a horrible situation
for that lovely guy to be in but
scientifically it's extremely powerful
so
i'm going to show you um we did in fact
have an opportunity the same guys in
japan
emailed me and said okay we're going to
be stimulating that electrode
what do we do
and i said okay have him look at faces
and have him look at other objects and
ask him if anything changes and i'm
going to show you a video of what
happens when that goes on
okay there we go
oh and i need to turn on the audio
okay here this is getting stimulated
right there and he says
he's such a good subject this guy
okay that tells us that that region is
causally involved in face perception is
it causally involved in perception of
things that aren't faces he's getting
stimulated in the same electrode he
doesn't know that there's a face area
he doesn't know what which electrode is
being stimulated
this is a kanji character on a card here
one more time
awesome huh what did we just learn
you can trigger it yeah
yeah
so what does that tell us about the
function of that region
why is this i mean it's amazing to see
no question but what does it tell us
scientifically
specific
yeah
how does it tell us that it's specific
because when you stimulate it like
it particularly sees a face
yeah
and what happens when he's looking at
things that aren't faces
yeah
so you know if that region was causally
involved in perception of things that
aren't faces
you might think that um that it would
distort the box would look different or
the ball would look different or the
kanji would look different it doesn't
there's just a face on top
so i think that's very strong evidence
that that region is not only causally
involved in face perception
but very specifically causally involved
in face perception only anybody get that
do i have to stop
okay
um okay i have another video consider
and we'll get back to this later
consider
um
other alternative hypotheses to this
this is this is pretty powerful like
this is more powerful than most of the
other things i showed you but there's
always ways to come up with alternative
hypotheses and that's the business we're
in here so be percolating on what other
control conditions you'd want from this
guy
to really believe these data